uh so the the
documentary but in general uh
it mentioned or kind of uh
emphasized and talked about aaron's
sexuality
or sort of they were discussing
basically
the idea that he was a homosexual
and some of the trauma
some of the suffering that he endured in
his life had to do with sort of
fear given the society of
of what his father would think of what
others around him sort of especially in
sport culture and football and so on
so i don't know in your interaction with
him
was uh do you think that maybe even
leading up to a suicide do you think
his uh struggle with
coming to terms with the sexuality had a
role to play in much of his difficulties
well i'm not going to talk about my
interactions
with them and anything i derived from
from that
but you know what i will say is that um
a story broke on the on the radio
uh at some point
uh during the the trial that aaron had
been in a same-sex
relationship with someone and some sport
local sportscasters local boston
sports casters or be really mushroomed
uh the the the story so um uh
he and everyone uh was aware of it
um you'll you also may know from the
court record
that the uh prosecutors floated
a uh specious theory
um for a minute but then backed off of
it that
you know that aaron was um that there
was some sort of
uh i guess gay rage at work with him and
that might be a
cause a motive for the killing
and uh luckily they they really backed
off with that that was
quite an offensive uh claim in in in
theory
so um but um to answer your question
more directly i mean i have no idea
why he he killed himself it was a a
surprise and a shock
um i was scheduled to go see him
like a couple days after it happened i
mean he was anxious
uh for um jose and i to come in and do
the appeal
from the murder which he was convicted
for he wanted us to take over that
appeal
um he was talking about going back to
football i mean he said
well you talk about this earlier you
talked about the sort of
innocent aspect of him he said you know
well iran maybe not maybe not the
patriots but you know i want to get back
in the league and i was like you know
aaron that's that's going to be tough
man
but he really but you know he really
believed it and
uh and then you know for a few days
later that to happen it was just it was
a real shock to me like when you look
back at that
at his story uh
does it make you sad very very
uh i i thought uh
so one i i believe he he he absolutely
did not
uh commit the the the crimes that we
could acquitted him on
uh i think that was the right answer uh
for for for that um uh
i don't know enough about bradley the
first case i'm sorry to make uh
make an opinion on but but in our case
uh
you know uh it was just he had the
misfortune of having a famous name
and the police department just really
just
just just really got got on them there
so um uh yes it's
it's i miss him a lot it was very very
sad surprising
yeah and and i mean just on the human
side of course we don't know the full
story but
just everything that led up to suicide
everything lied up to
an incredible professional football
player you know
that whole story if uh remarkably
talented
athlete remarkably talented athlete and
it has to do with all the
all the possible trajectories right that
we can take through life as we were
talking about before
and some of them lead to uh
to suicide sadly enough and
it's it's always tragic when you have
absolutely yeah some
you know somebody with uh with great
potential
uh resulting in the things that happen
right
you